vamos a las noticias de la economía
actualizamos con Daniela Blandón Daniela
continuamos hablando de los actores de
Hollywood Así es Ángela es la noticia
económica del día sin duda alguna Bueno
entonces no hubo acuerdo eso ya está
claro y estamos esperando un inminente
anuncio de la junta del sindicato para
confirmar que se van a unir a la huelga
Claro que sí pues fracasaron entonces
estas negociaciones anoche ahora se va a
saber más tarde si se van a huelga estos
más de 160.000 actores sindicalizados en
abstra que se unirían posiblemente a los
11.500 guionistas que ya están en paro
desde el dos de mayo pasado y sus
demandas son prácticamente las mismas
como lo veníamos conversando con nuestro
invitado Y es que tanto sus salarios
como el pago de los Derechos residuales
sea más justo los derechos residuales
son los que se refieren al porcentaje
que reciben cuando las producciones en
las que trabajan son vendidas a terceros
por ejemplo a las cadenas de televisión
ellos también están pidiendo garan tías
de que su trabajo no va a ser
reemplazado por la Inteligencia
artificial o que si lo hacen pues tengan
una compensación adecuada ya el ceo de
Disney Robert ager dijo hoy que esta
inminente huelga tendría un efecto
devastador sobre la industria
cinematográfica
que pueden esperar o que podemos esperar
mejor Daniela los que pues vemos todos
estos productos que vienen directo desde
Hollywood Pues un eventual huelga de
actores detendría toda la producción de
películas y programas de televisión con
guión en Estados Unidos esto con
excepciones de las producciones
independientes que no están cubiertas
por contratos laborales con sindicatos
hoy ya están detenidas las dramas y las
comedias la producción de programas como
stranger things Está detenida también en
los programas que van en vivo como los
que mencionábamos de la ley del show en
otoño próximo Entonces esta parrilla va
a estar repleta de reality shows y de
repeticiones Y es que esta huelga llega
a efectuarse los servicios de
transmisión como Netflix o Prime video
de Amazon podrían seguir ofreciendo
programas en idiomas locales producidos
en otros lugares como Corea e India pero
sus producciones en Hollywood sí
estarían en pausa los programas de
noticias continuarían con normalidad
porque sus escritores están cubiertos
por un sindicato diferente y si hablamos
de las películas pues estas soportarían
un poco más porque tardan dos o tres
años en producirse sin embargo esto
depende también del tiempo que dure la
huelga porque Blade y thunderbolts de
Marvel ya tienen retrasos como
consecuencia de la de la huelga de
guionistas que viene desde hace casi
tres meses y seguramente nos van a
llegar noticias de más producciones que
se van a retrasar por culpa de estas
huelgas bien
A pesar de estas preocupaciones que
surgen entre estos gremios de la
Industria Del entretenimiento el centro
de la discordia avanza y a pasos
agigantados la Inteligencia artificial y
además se amplía la competencia Claro
que sí Además este es uno de los puntos
clave en estas negociaciones porque
ellos están teniendo que la Inteligencia
artificial los vaya a reemplazar en su
momento ahora elon musk y Google están
agilizando ese paso simultáneamente para
competirle a Microsoft y a su
herramienta de Inteligencia artificial
por un lado El Magnate lanzó su startup
a pesar de que hace pocas semanas el
mismo había dicho que esta tecnología
debería de tenerse hasta que tuviera una
correcta regulación al mismo tiempo el
buscador Google anunció la llegada de su
aplicación Bart a Brasil y a Europa y
dijo que ya está disponible en más de 40
idiomas incluidos árabe chino alemán
hindi y español bardey piti que son los
más avanzados son programas con
apariencia humana que están utilizando
Inteligencia artificial generativa para
mantener conversaciones con los usuarios
y también para responder a innumerables
preguntas una tecnología que nos sigue
volando la cabeza Definitivamente sí que
va a reemplazar muchos empleos en un
futuro según pues se hayan dicho en
diferentes estudios es que esa es la
contradicción genera tanta emoción como
angustia Así que veremos Pues cómo se
equilibra después el mercado Daniela
vamos a hacer un cambio para hablar de
nuestra región el dólar marcó un nuevo
récord en el mercado informal de
Argentina hacemos el seguimiento de la
situación allí Claro que sí la divisa
estadounidense subió el miércoles 5
pesos en el mercado paralelo hasta un
nuevo máximo de 503 pesos por unidad
veremos cómo se comporta el día de hoy
Eso quiere decir que ha acumulado un
alza del
45,3% en lo que va del año en el Estatal
banco de la nación o sea donde el dólar
ya es el del mercado formal también está
en un máximo de
275,5 pesos para la venta al público
Aunque sí hay que hacer énfasis en que
ahí en el banco Estatal las operaciones
se restringen a 200 dólares mensuales
por cada persona y bajo ciertas
condiciones todo esto se da en un
contexto obviamente de crisis económica
de una inflación que ya supera el 114
por ciento según anual según los más
recientes datos entregados por la
oficina de estadística y aquí Daniela
Argentina podría incluso ser un buen
ejemplo de nuestro tema siguiente y son
las críticas que lanza Naciones Unidas
que se envuelven más duras contra el
sistema financiero mundial Pues por De
dónde viene la crítica Pues de que en
2022 la deuda pública mundial alcanzó un
récord de 92 millones de dólares y los
países en desarrollo están cargando con
una cantidad desproporcionada dentro de
ese Total como usted lo mencionaba
Argentina es uno de los países es por lo
menos el país que con el que el fondo
monetario internacional tiene su crédito
más amplio según la ONU algunos de esos
países más pobres del mundo se están
viendo obligados cada vez más a elegir
entre pagar su deuda o mejor los
intereses de esa deuda o invertir en sus
ciudadanos
billian people unos 3.300 millones de
personas casi la mitad de la humanidad
vive en países que gastan más en los
pagos de intereses profundos que en la
educación o la salud Because Mouse y sin
embargo debido a que la mayoría de estas
deudas insostenibles se concentran en
los países pobres no se considera que
representen un riesgo sistémico para el
sistema financiero mundial
esto es un Espejismo 3.300 millones de
personas están más que en un riesgo
sistémico en una falla sistémica los
mercados parecen no estar sufriendo pero
la gente sí
tipo ar cuál educación financiera Sí
desde la base está el problema claro y
es que podemos verlo con las mismas
personas el mismo ejemplo personal una
las personas tienen hoy en día que haber
enfrentadas a si pagan los intereses de
sus tarjetas de crédito o si comen Pues
estamos muy mal Daniela Pero bueno
Muchas gracias a usted por traernos la
noticia para pensar en ella y
seguramente para mejorar nuestras
finanzas Daniela Así es nos vemos acá
Entonces mañana Claro que sí